So our goal is to write code now
that computes the formula that we worked out earlier--
that we want to compute the rank for each page.
The thing that we're going to do--instead of
using this recursive definition,
we're going to write a loop that goes through the timesteps,
and we're going to figure out how many timesteps we want.
The more timesteps, the more accurate rankings we'll have--
but the longer it will take.
So we'll just pick a value
for the maximum number of timesteps
and we'll make our loop go through those steps,
computing these equations.
So let's work out the code to do that.
So now that we've got the graph,
all that's left to do is figure out how to use it
to compute the Page Ranks.
So to do that, we'll make a procedure called, "compute.ranks".
It takes, as input, a graph that gives the link structure.
So, as an example, we have our graph
that has the URLs--
and each URL, followed by the link of pages that it links to .
And this is the graph that was produced by our crawler.
And crawlweb produced, as outputs,
a graph as well as an index.
We're going to use the graph as the input to compute.ranks.
So the output from compute.ranks will be a dictionary,
giving, for each URL, its urank--
the ranking that we compute, using our formula--
and the higher the rank, the better.
And what we're going to do, once we have those ranks--
and this last part is going to be left as a homework assignment for you--
we're going to--instead of having just "lookup",
we're going to have "lookupbest".
And lookupbest will take 3 inputs.
It will take the keyword we're looking for.
It will also take the index that came from the crawl,
and it will also take the ranks.
And from those 3 inputs, the index will give us
all of the pages that contain the keyword.
And then what lookupbest will do is
use the ranks to find the highest Rank Page
and give that as the output.
So once we've done that, you'll have a complete search engine.
You'll have a crawler that starts from a seed,
finds pages, produces an index, produces a graph;
that graph is the input to compute.ranks;
compute.ranks uses our page-ranking algorithm
to figure out the pages that are most popular.
And then lookupbest takes the graph, as input--
the index as input--and the keyword,
finds the pages that contain that keyword,
and identifies the one that's best, using the ranks.
So that's what you'll have, after the homework of this unit.
We're going to finish compute.ranks now
and leave it up to you to define lookupbest, as a homework question.